- [Brittany] When you're
getting on the ice
and pairs of skaters are
already racing before you,
it can be very, very noisy,
but the second I step
on the ice for my race,
I become hyper focused.
My name is Brittany Bowe,
and I am an Olympic
long track speed skater.
- [Narrator] Speed skating
is a competitive sport
raced around an oval course.
Athletes compete at speeds
up to 36 miles per hour.
The fastest skater wins
and races can be so close,
champions are determined by split seconds.
While they compete inside
during the Olympics,
athletes train outdoors,
skating in freezing
temperatures and falling snow.
- [Brittany] The moment
before the gun goes off
is one of the hardest moments of the race.
There's this push-pull that's happening
because you want to be very calm, relaxed,
but at the same time,
you're nervous and your heart
is beating out of your chest.
My vision and hearing become so narrow,
it sounds like you're
the only person in there.
At this moment, you could
hear a pin drop in the oval.
- [Man] Ready?
(gun fires)
When you're hitting corners,
a gravitational force
feels like it's trying
to pull you right off of the track.
When you're going around the
track at these high speeds,
fighting the gravitational forces,
the pain that you feel in
your legs is unimaginable.
It's a sensation of heaviness,
and it almost feels like
your muscles are suffocating
because of all of the pressure.
When you cross the finish line
and you see a number
one next to your name,
it feels like all of the pain
that I just endured was totally worth it.